[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en México
donde comienzan los procesos para
Designar al sucesor de amlo de López
Obrador para ello nos acompañan en este
estudio tres invitados les presento ya a
Florencia Ángeles corresponsal de la
doble u radio bienvenida
en la organización global iniciativa de
lucha contra el crimen organizado
bienvenido Buenos días gracias Gracias
doctora en civilización americana
investigadora en la universidad de la
sorbona bienvenida marilor el futuro
político de México hoy nuestro asunto en
Primera Plana
a un año de las elecciones en México la
pelea por la presidencia es ya la
principal fuente de tensiones en todos
los frentes con decenas de políticos de
todo el espectro que quieren sentarse en
la silla presidencial y ya han comenzado
a apostar sus fichas La promesa de la
oposición y del oficialismo es que será
en unos días cuando empiecen a tener un
más claro de cómo se definirá definirá a
los candidatos y quiénes serán los
protagonistas en 2024 el proceso para
Designar al sucesor del presidente amlo
en morena va a iniciarse Precisamente en
julio hoy en Primera Plana analizamos
cómo está esa carrera por el poder en
México que va a estar tan conectado y
más a otro futuro político el de su
vecino del Norte El de Estados Unidos
repasemos algunas portadas este artículo
del diario El Universal se pregunta por
qué fracasan los modelos de seguridad en
México y cómo tras 20 años el país ha
normalizado la violencia ni la guerra
contra el narco ni el abrazos no balazos
han conseguido los resultados esperados
desde enfoques distintos dice el diario
El País que Claudia sheinbaum se afianza
como la líder en la carrera presidencial
luego veremos Quién es algo con lo que
coincide de economist que titula México
podría elegir a su primera presidenta
bueno Florencia el sucesor de amlo
contra toda la oposición es el un poco
el escenario que se va a Designar en
México a corto plazo esa batalla
electoral que vamos a ver claro por
supuesto ahorita la primera digamos que
la primera fuerza es decir quién va a
ser el candidato y contra él no
realmente en los sondeos la mayoría la
tiene evidentemente el partido de que
fundó López Obrador morena Y entonces
vemos A toda la oposición que se está
uniendo Estados Unidos contra amlo o
contra su sucesor No ya sea la izquierda
con el PRD también el pri el partido
Acción Nacional y evidentemente también
otros movimientos independientes que
están saliendo en contra de de este
movimiento de regeneración nacional es
algo como muy transversal porque
encontramos Román que la oposición hay
absolutamente de todo entonces este
panorama es un poco no es el clásico
panorama derecha contra izquierda no hay
un panorama que se está dibujando pero
que también cambia mucho según el estado
según elecciones muy locales no hay
muchos arreglos locales está pasando
ahora en en Coahuila por ejemplo donde
hay elecciones esta semana este domingo
se ven reacomodos que se dan de nuevo
con arreglos negociaciones muy puntuales
muy locales la oposición es un bloque
muy disparate en el en el país que va a
tener muchísimo que ganar en jugar estos
arreglos locales también Creo que van a
ser muchísimos dibujos este que vamos a
tener que ver estado por estado casi
municipio por municipio y obviamente las
elecciones del año pasado del año
próximo luego os voy a preguntar por
algunos de los nombres que suenan
marilor la situación en la frontera es
uno de los puntos débiles de la
Administración amlo el reciente incendio
de un albergue puso el foco nuevamente
en la situación y en la frontera Sur la
situación no es mucho mejor no sí sí
exactamente y de una manera podemos
decir que bueno el presidente
López Obrador está haciendo el trabajo
de los Estados Unidos porque al lado
estudian del estereo de Estados Unidos
de la frontera las cosas están como
relativamente tranquilas pero al otro
hay más de 25.000 migrantes
en albergues o en campamentos
improvisados y también
el presidente López Obrador
está ayudando a los Estados Unidos con
la frontera Sur Entonces sí en este
sentido se puede hablar de una
tercerización del trabajo migratorio de
los Estados Unidos
del título 42 luego le voy a preguntar
mayor Coco Cómo va a afectar a en el
futuro todas las incertidumbres que deja
ese fin del título 42 del que tanto
hemos hablado durante estas últimas
semanas Pero antes hay un hombre que
suena mucho el proceso para Designar al
sucesor de hablo en morena va a
iniciarse en el mes de julio suena mucho
el nombre de Claudia sheinbaum Florencia
Quién es Claudia Y qué destacamos de su
acción al frente de la alcaldía de
Ciudad de México recordemos Ella es una
académica estudió física en la UNAM
también un doctorado en energía y
ella realmente empezó con mucho un
carácter ambientalista No de hecho fue
consultora de la ONU para justamente un
estudio sobre el cambio climático y ya
en cuanto política Carlos haya la
recordamos por ser secretaria del medio
ambiente cuando López Obrador era jefe
de gobierno de la Ciudad de México ella
estaba en esta en este cargo que duró
justamente todo el gobierno de amlo y
después de ahí se fue a la jefatura
delegacional en Tlalpan de allí después
saltó a esta factura de esta jefatura
del gobierno de la Ciudad de México
ahora alcaldía y justamente pues destaca
que es la primera mujer que fue electa
como tal en este cargo de ahí también
que llega con esta fuerza a hacer una
buena digamos en cuanto a cifras no para
una buena candidata para suceder a amlo
y también es una de las fieles al
presidente eh finalmente Exactamente no
destaca que hay dos nombres además de de
en general dos nombres que se perfilan
que es el de ella y el de Marcelo ebrard
que es el canciller de México pero por
el momento las encuestas dicen que en
México
preferiría a una aspirante presidencial
mujer a una presidenta mujer y ahí es
donde quizá Claudia sheinbaum tendría
este apoyo o este pues sí mayor digamos
una una mayor presencia para esta
contienda electoral Román desde su
organización Se lucha contra el crimen
organizado sin duda la migración está
controlada por el crimen organizado en
muchos rincones de del país es el caso
en varios puntos del paso El poder del
crimen organizado está siendo la gran
problemática de estos años de amlo
creo que el El poder del Poder del
crimen organizado en México hoy No
necesariamente ha cambiado drásticamente
sinceramente creo que desde la
perspectiva muy local de nuevo lo que
vemos es una transformación creo del
paisaje de cómo operan las redes del
crimen organizado teníamos una visión
muy atada al narcotráfico al tráfico de
drogas no una visión de que los cárteles
de la droga los narcos son los que
realmente se ocupan el tráfico de drogas
del cual tiran este poder dinero
etcétera hoy creo que lo que sí vemos es
una instalación de una unas redes una
especie de régimen mucho más mafioso de
alguna manera es muy difícil
distinguir si son traficantes si son
bandas que se dedican a la extorsión
bandas que se dedican al secuestro
bandas que se dedican a
x actividades delictivas no estas redes
también son mucho más difícil que antes
creo separarlas del poder político del
poder empresarial y diferentes intereses
que operan a nivel local lo que sí hay y
que es cada vez más difícil por este
esta dificultad de distinguir es saber
quién es el bueno Y quién es el malo con
quién estás hablando de que se ocupan en
qué están metidos por una falta creo que
es una falta que sigue y que el gobierno
actual no ha resuelto Es la falta
absoluta o casi absoluta de justicia en
el país No o sea sin un sistema de
Justicia operante no vamos a poner no
vamos a poder tener a ninguna política
pública de seguridad que resuelva esta
situación tal y como está hoy redes de
crimen organizado que que manejan los
flujos migratorios no marilock sí sí
exactamente hay muchos migrantes que
quieren pasar cruzar Especialmente con
el título 42 de que estábamos hablando
porque
pensaban que las reglas iban a cambiar
con este con el fin del título el
presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador se afana por
completar Ya ven que vamos tratando
diferentes aspectos de lo que de lo que
México encima de la mesa se afana por
completar un proyecto el del tren maya
en los dos años que le quedan a su
mandato en contra de las objeciones de
ambientalistas arqueólogos y las
personas que bucean en los cenotes
Florencia Por qué se afana el presidente
en continuar cueste lo que cueste con
este megaproyecto es una muy buena
pregunta Carlos porque realmente ese
digamos que el proyecto Faro de su
gobierno ha tenido otro por ejemplo el
que ya construyó el aeropuerto Felipe
Ángeles que es el aeropuerto alterno en
la Ciudad de México pero particularmente
el tren Maya tiene gran digamos
protección por parte del mismo
presidente de hecho no solamente están
estas críticas que dices ambientalistas
al proyecto sin incluso decisiones
judiciales decisiones judiciales que el
presidente la verdad las está dejando a
un lado diciendo que a él no le han
informado por ejemplo recientemente hubo
un juzgado de distrito en Yucatán que
suspendió ya tres tramos cuatro tramos
perdón de este tren Maya y el presidente
Dice que no ha recibido la notificación
y que el tren va que el tren va a
avanzar que a finales de este año va a
operar e incluso ya lo ha catalogado
como un asunto de seguridad nacional eso
te habla también de la insistencia de la
protección que él tiene a este proyecto
que evidentemente impulsa la economía en
la zona realmente a México no es algo
nuevo siempre se ha dicho que se
necesitan estas redes ferroviarias y que
el el país se impulse el problema y que
le critican mucho es que no ha habido un
estudio de impacto ambiental y un
estudio también de impacto de suelo en
esta zona que como bien decías están los
cenotes están es la mayor red de Cuevas
subterráneas en el mundo y entonces eso
que los ambientalistas dicen que se
puede deteriorar y ahora en lugar de
atraer al turismo que se va a hacer qué
es lo que va a ver el turismo si estas
reservas se ven afectadas Román Por qué
se afana el presidente en este
megaproyecto creo que el proyecto en sí
Hay que verlo como parte como bien decía
Florencia de otros megaproyectos no va
de la mano del aeropuerto va de la mano
del corredor tras o sea oceánico que
quedó mucho que hablar en las últimas
semanas que conectará el Pacífico con el
Atlántico a través este de Oaxaca
Tabasco el plan de seguridad nacional o
sea de hecho el papel del ejército de la
guardia nacional o el hecho de catalogar
ahora el proyecto tren Maya como
seguridad nacional viene creo dentro de
un de un papel de un protagonismo
político que no que de alguna manera no
desvía de lo que había planteado el
primer día a pesar de que haya oposición
a pesar de que haya este hoy en día
preocupaciones muy fuertes por un tema
ambiental el presidente Sigue avanzando
con esos proyectos como para de alguna
forma tener algo que presentar muy
concretamente cuando termine su
administración cueste lo que cueste no
también con una visión creo bastante
cortoplacista en este caso a pesar de la
infraestructura Que obviamente quedará
para para siempre si se si se termina no
lo cierto Es que bueno cada mañana el
presidente continúa vendiendo sus
proyectos la acción de gobierno en ese
ejercicio televisivo llamado la mañanera
que sorprende desde otros puntos de
vista desde otros lugares desde otras
latitudes critica los medios que no le
gustan da golpes a sus adversarios
políticos
le vale Este potente elemento de
comunicación es eficaz este estilo
populista es plebiscitado Florencia a él
le vale o sea Es decir desde que era él
era jefe de gobierno en la Ciudad de
México usaba esta mañanera de la misma
manera para imponer agenda Entonces qué
hace la conferencia de prensa a las seis
de la mañana no ya define la agenda
nacional para que hacen los periodistas
Bueno después ir con otras fuentes y
responder que qué le responde al
presidente que esta mañana dijo Es de
esa manera él es el omnipresente en la
en la agenda nacional y realmente se
especuló mucho Sobre si va a seguir o no
con este ejercicio durante su su
presidencia cuando lo inició algunos
pensaban que nada más era como el primer
año al final de cuenta lo vemos que le
ha resultado y también es sin duda para
él una manera en la responderle a todos
los críticos a todos los críticos que no
siempre lo hace de la mejor manera se le
cuestiona mucho también este dejo a
veces autoritario para decir que no
estás conmigo estás en contra en contra
mía claro por supuesto Sí sí sí
realmente es un ejercicio de resistencia
para muchos pero bueno también le
permite abordar diversos aspectos y
también se ha cuestionado quienes acuden
a esta mañanera Y si hay o no realmente
una libertad de expresión desde este
recinto vamos a hacer una breve pausa en
este punto a vuelta vamos a hablar de la
conexión que hay entre el proceso
electoral mexicano y el de su vecino del
Norte El de Estados Unidos hasta ahora
Todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar es de mujeres en ellas hoy
hablamos de nuestra diversidad nuestros
logros y nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
hoy en France 24 y 24 punto com
France 24 el arte en todas sus formas
libertad
seguimos en Primera Plana de radiofrance
internacional y France 24 esta semana
analizando el proceso electoral que se
avecina en México de selección de
candidatos para suceder a amlo lo
hacemos con la periodista Florencia
ángeles con el experto senior en la
organización global iniciativa Román
lekook y con la doctora en civilización
americana Maggie log Hace tres semanas
expiró el llamado título 42 en la
frontera méxico-estados Unidos el fin de
la controvertida normal migratoria de
Trump que permitía la expulsión rápida
de inmigrantes que eran devueltos en
cuestión de minutos a México deja paso a
un nuevo régimen plagado de
incertidumbres con muchas incógnitas que
además va a entroncar con los procesos
electorales tanto en México como en
Estados Unidos que casi son vasos
comunicantes no Mari lord King
certidumbres deja sobre la mesa el fin
del título 42 Sí exactamente bueno los
presidentes hablaron de la importancia
de la colaboración entre los dos países
y
capítulo 8 va a introducir
consecuencias más estrictas para los los
migrantes removidos de la frontera y
también la administración de biden
introdujo mi nueva reglas la semana
pasada que negarían el asilo a los casi
todos los migrantes que cruzan sin tener
la autorización y van a abrir también
100 centros de procesamiento de
migrantes en Colombia en Guatemala y
para reducir la posibilidad de de de de
de de cruzar la frontera desde la
frontera entre los Estados Unidos los
Estados Unidos y México y México también
ha acordado seguir aceptando 30.000
migrantes al mes de Cuba de Haití de
Nicaragua de Venezuela Bueno si llegando
por por avión entonces
la colaboración sí va a seguir entre los
dos países
va a seguir pero luego como decíamos
esto entronca también con los que el
proceso electoral mexicano va a ser
paralelo al de Estados Unidos y mucho va
a tener que ver quién es el próximo
inquilino de la Casa Blanca Román Sí o
sea hay una incertidumbre y hay un
panorama que está por abrirse no este
proceso paralelos si lo cual lo cual
creo que es bastante O sea me imagino
que ya sucedió no tengo el dato la
verdad pero en el pasado sí
hay algo muy interesante bastante
inédito que se va a abrir y que en ambos
casos creo que a pesar de que obviamente
no no sabemos lo que va a pasar ambos
países comparten unas campañas
larguísimas no campanas electorales que
van a durar mucho tiempo son maratónicas
en ambos casos es una carrera de fondo
en el que apenas va a empezar y que van
a empezar a dibujarse quién quién va a
ir como con qué apoyos etcétera etcétera
no O sea ambos países van a van a van a
enfrentarse
a nivel nacional interno y creo que muy
rápido van a empezar a enfrentarse de
forma binacional no pegando a Estados
Unidos Pegándole a México y dialogando
en estas campañas con un par de temas
migración fentanilo este seguridad
nacional seguramente enfrentarse para
luego tener que sentarse a la mesa y
tener que volver a negociar Y pactar
esto es un poco una una visión electoral
y luego una visión de la Real política
ambos para sus electores es decir es el
elemento que le va a dar justamente
voten por mí porque estoy en contra o a
favor no de lo que está proponiendo el
vecino no O sea realmente Eso sirve muy
bien para los electores más allá de que
después colaboren es tiene que haber una
colaboración somos países vecinos y esto
hemos tenido desde hace años coinciden o
no las políticas de cada gobierno sin
duda eso es un hecho pero para para sus
electores a los dos les va a servir este
proceso electoral paralelo tras cuatro
años en el poder no sé si tenemos ya una
perspectiva suficiente Florencia para
valorar si el México de amlo es mejor en
términos de seguridad que el de sus
antecesores en el cargo o es muy
complicado valorarlo de esta forma Sí yo
creo que es muy complicado no ha habido
una en cifras al menos no ha habido una
mejoría o una mejora Mejor dicho
finalmente él ha optado por sacar al
ejército también o echar mano al
ejército para controlar varios temas no
algo que también se le ha criticado por
parte de las organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos eh sin embargo como decía Román
hace rato el el la cuestión del crimen
organizado es mucho más amplia y
tristemente No únicamente depende del
gobierno en turno Sino de todos los
poderes alrededor de Entonces no se
puede decir que hay una mejora realmente
en cuanto a cifras la incluso para los
periodistas también vamos de mal en peor
en cuanto asesinatos de premisas en lo
que va de ese sexenio Así que también
ese es un gran reto para el próximo
gobierno del presidente sea de cuál sea
el partido sin duda la lucha con el
crimen organizado Román antes veíamos un
artículo del universal que decía que ni
el enfoque de la guerra al narco ni el
preventivo han cosechado los resultados
esperados Qué puede hacer el país ante
esta normalización sin resultado es
decir Quizá no hay una receta mágica
Pero qué lecciones puedes traer de los
modelos que sí que ha probado claro creo
ahí Y a partir de este de este artículo
del del universal creo que de hecho
parte quizás del error es pensar que la
guerra contra el narco es muy diferente
a lo que se hace hoy por un tema
realmente de cómo llamas a tu política
pública de seguridad no creo que lo que
se está haciendo hoy no es muy diferente
sinceramente de lo que se hizo en el
sexenio pasado en el anterior o
realmente una política pública basada en
una reacción en un despliegue de Fuerza
Armada para luchar contra carteles de la
droga básicamente es eso no Y eso sigue
sigue sucediendo creo que lo que
mencionábamos antes frente al panorama
del país en términos criminales pero
sobre todo de nuevo en términos de
corrupción de extorsión de penetración
de redes mafiosas en la política lo cual
se ve en cada elección O de hecho en
cada vida pública política casi
cotidiana en el país para mí el fracaso
más grande de esta estrategia es saber
fracasado en implementar o en
desarrollar un sistema de Justicia que
funcione hoy en día la catástrofe del
país es que los niveles de impunidad
están por las nubes en general el nivel
de cifra negra o sea delitos que no se
reportan ni se investigan están
Generalmente entre 98 y 99% es decir el
1% de los crímenes y delitos en el país
se investigan lo cual es una locura
sinceramente ninguna política pública de
seguridad es decir fuerzas públicas en
la calle básicamente va a lograr
resolver lo que pasa en el país si las
fiscalías no hacen su trabajo si el
poder judicial no hace su trabajo si no
hay investigación cosa que en México
creo que ninguna y ningún ciudadano
Confía en que si te sucede algo la
justicia te va a ayudar sino más bien
todo lo contrario y eso eso si no se si
no se resuelve podemos seguir poniendo
Guardia nacional ejército policial no
vamos a ir a ningún lado parece tan
lógico y a la vez es tan complicado no
la cifra no de que no hay investigación
para incluso ya de interponer una
denuncia como dice algo mal por esta
Falta de confianza las autoridades y
saber que no hay ningún ningún castigo
la gente ni siquiera interpone denuncias
Y tenemos incluso una sub cifra de los
delitos que se están cometiendo en en
México
siempre se ha considerado hablando de
migración que México es un país de
acogida esa esa tradición se ha ido
perdiendo o es algo que todavía está ahí
bueno la cuestión de la migración es
difícil porque es un desafío para la
administración del del presidente y
también hay muchas presiones de parte de
los Estados Unidos en particular de la
Administración anterior de las de la
administración de Trump Entonces
yo creo que sí
Por una parte sí siguen
el país sigue tratando de de ayudar a
los migrantes que que están llegando al
país están diciendo por ejemplo que las
políticas que que lo que están haciendo
es para el bienestar de los migrantes
para evitar una crisis humanitaria que
sí de una parte sí es cierto es para
evitarlo pero también la administración
del presidente mexicano sigue criticando
porque
podría ser más para los
los migrantes
contabas de la tercerización no de de de
y que al final responde a la real
política no por mucho que un país tenga
cultura de
de recibir a migrantes no sé crimen
organizado violencia feminicidios
economía ecología de todos estos asuntos
que estamos planteando y sobre la mesa
Cuáles van a marcar más la carrera
electoral Florencia Yo creo que tiene
que ver mucho Bueno de ya el poder de
compra también que México se ha ido
bastante afectado en los próximos en los
últimos meses pero también la seguridad
sin duda y también la cuestión de
feminicidios yo creo que ha habido un
despertar ya lo había pero un despertar
muy fuerte y muy casos al menos el eco
mediático es distinto exactamente
en las marchas que cada vez son más lo
puede ser violentas Pero bueno que más
se ve este hartazgo de la gente entonces
Generalmente el feminicidio y y esta
violencia hacia las mujeres va también a
marcar la agenda
para los es un punto importante que
tienen que tratar los candidatos
presidenciales y bueno el cometer crimen
organizado como dicen la estrategia de
seguridad pública finalmente cada año es
un punto de los de los que se ve en las
en las campañas No veremos en esta
ocasión de hace alguna alternativa que
pueda surgir realmente verdadera pero
creo que son los temas que podrían
abarcar en la próxima que creen de que
por dónde pueden ir los tiros de todos
estos temas que estamos de los que
estamos hablando el tema de seguridad va
a estar este seguramente creo que es un
tema hoy en día tan tan difícil de
acatar políticamente que No
necesariamente meterte a una pelea de
argumentar si funciona o no funciona no
creo que políticamente sea muy
redituable para para un opositor por
ejemplo no es muy difícil enfrentarte al
presidente o al que o a la persona que
le siga dentro de morena y decirle tu tu
estrategia fracasado ganado porque
siempre hay un argumento que vas a poder
jugar en A favor o en contra el tema
creo del del poder adquisitivo el tema
económico el tema social en el país si
va a estar muy fuerte y ahí es todavía
más difícil hoy en día por la verdad
dificultades de acceso a la información
en México evaluar otros programas
estrella del gobierno actual que son
jóvenes construyendo el futuro son
centenares de miles de becas repartidas
cada mes sembrando vida también o sea
estos programas sociales programas
sociales del del gobierno de amlo que sí
se han implementado y que no sabemos muy
bien evaluar porque de nuevo es muy
difícil acceder a esa información sin
embargo son becas son programas que sí
se distribuyen cada mes que tienen un
impacto fenomenal a nivel local que no
logramos evaluar bien pero que sí tienen
ese impacto Y esa movilización social al
al al siguiente o la siguiente candidata
de de morena para el año al año próximo
sí va a ser una palanca muy fuerte para
movilizar bases
que Añadir a los temas de los que por
dónde va a ir la cuestión migratoria va
a estar ahí en la campaña electoral
claramente vivimos la semana pasada
presidente mexicano criticó muy
duramente a round Sánchez que acaba de
lanzar su campaña para la nominación
republicana y criticó la ley que él está
tratando de
de promover el proyecto antimigración de
de Florida y y está el presidente llamó
a los votantes latinos no respaldar a
ronda Sánchez en la elección quizá de
todo lo que hablamos hoy no sé la
normalización de la violencia quizás sea
el tema que más que más castiga a México
no como la cuestión de cómo sea por
normal ya sí realmente el hecho de que
des por entendido que hay diario este
reporte de de homicidios no de de
feminicidios ya lo decíamos también e
incluso también de otros delitos y Y la
verdad es que la sociedad ha aprendido a
vivir con ello y de ahí también a veces
que se que se normalice y que se pega la
importancia
para combatirlo muchísimas gracias a los
tres ha sido un placer que nos acompañen
hoy analizando el futuro de México y a
todos ustedes les esperamos aquí la
próxima semana quien en Primera Plana
gracias